[Music]
after working in the mep construction
business for almost more than nine years
i felt it was finally time for me
to pursue my passion and focus on my
dreams the lockdown was a blessing in
disguise for me since i could complete
the course and turn my career around to
a path which i want to follow for the
rest of my life hi i'm nitin kusari and
i have completed two masters program
from simply learn i work at exl as a
data scientist here in mumbai and i have
to thank simply learn for the same i was
always inclined towards maths and
statistics so during the pandemic i
decided to upskill myself i took up the
data scientist master's program and then
later artificial intelligence engineers
masters program the decision to change
my career and domain was a very risky
one since i had to look after my family
responsibilities also but the idea of
becoming a data scientist was something
unique and catchy and i had wished for
it for a long time i found simply learn
scores very user friendly the app was
very good the learning content was good
and you can record the lectures which
was a very good advantage for a working
professional like me the instructors
were very knowledgeable and cooperative
the examples provided during the
lectures made it easy to relate it with
your current work i joined godrej and
boys ene in 2015. and worked as a deputy
manager in their mep engineering wing
while i was working there i completed my
mba in 2018 at the nasi munji institute
of management studies and i was
recognized in the top 6 students on the
dain's list i learned statistical
concepts and advanced analytics during
mba i started experimenting on my
strengths i read various articles
attended webinars and several seminars
on data science and what it is all about
and finally in 2020 i took the leap of
faith it was a big risk but simply learn
helped me achieve my goals after
completing my course i joined icic bank
as a data science and analytics manager
where i got good exposure to programming
languages like sql and python then later
i managed to crack the data scientist
job at exl with an amazing package and
the best working culture i'm a very
family oriented person i like to make
people happy i am very happy and content
with where i am in my life at the moment
simply learn has helped me believe that
there can be a lockdown but ambition and
motivation cannot be locked down on your
studies and goals i hope that this data
science journey of mind could make an
impact on at least one person out there
keep learning
[Music]